[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Dustin is
up next in Charleston West Virginia
what's going on man hey guys thanks for
taking my call sure uh my wife and I we
um we feel that we make too much money
to have to you know each month worry
that are we putting enough in savings
are we doing the right thing with our
money uh the the interest rates have
went back on student loans uh we never
had student loans prior to co um and
then postco you know we probably weren't
aggressive enough paying off student
loans with uh interest off we probably
did things with with that money that we
shouldn't have done but see if maybe get
a little guidance on on what how to
tackle student loans the best and are we
maybe saving enough uh and budgeting
doing our budget right okay yeah so how
much student loan debt do you guys have
uh she has 203,000 right now what's her
degree in
uh anesthesia good okay and is she how
much is she making a year uh combin we
gross about 340 combined 340 okay so
that's the student loans and then any
other debt how much do youall owe on the
cars uh we have two vehicles and we have
we also have two mortgages we have a
mortgage on our house and we have the
farm mortgage land mortgage separate uh
we rent um an old mobile home on the
farm that covers
that payment though okay so how much and
the the cars how much debt is on them
they're the one they're both a little
over 50,000 we owe on them 50,000 each
okay each yeah and then how much and
then any other Consumer Debt besides the
mortgage no we got mortgage Vehicles
student loans okay yeah I mean yeah and
I I mean I can I I with these numbers
I'm like yeah you you owe as much as you
make a year so it is going to feel it's
going to feel tight is um do you guys
have any
savings uh we probably got 25 right now
we've just you know like I said we
weren't as responsible maybe as we
should have been when interest rates
were off the student loans we you know
spent a 100,000 building a building a
new barn and right just doing whatever
doing whatever you want and now you now
every month you're committed to paying
that and you're thinking maybe I should
have been more responsible for the past
two years totally um so how much you
know how much should we think about
having savings should we go a different
route on put less investing inv are you
doing any investing right now um we both
max out uh for a once okay okay well
that's going to free up a whole bunch of
money if we paused that temporarily
wouldn't it uh yeah but you know should
we do that or um if I had $300,000 in
Consumer Debt I would definitely pause
investing and here's here's the reason
because I know you're going listen you
guys are smart people you're really good
at math the TR truth is making
$340,000 you guys should retire multi
multi multi multi-millionaires the
problem is there's a lot of people just
like you out there who don't retire with
that because they think well I'm just
going to hang on to this debt I'm not
I'm kind of comfortable we're just doing
a bunch of things at once but we're not
really making any progress so I think
you guys could crush this $300,000 in
debt in two
years less than that would be uh yeah
that would be good it's just you know so
maybe
what we're putting in in retirement
right now I would pause all investing
Dustin I would take your $25,000 in
savings and this is going to make you
feel real uncomfortable I would take it
down to a th000 and I would throw
24,000 at at this debt and and if I were
you Dustin I'm like if it's $100,000 in
cars even though your income can
somewhat justify it we don't want it
more than half of your annual income so
it technically could justify it but
almost for the act of it I would just I
would get rid of them how much do you
think you could sell them for uh we
could probably clear 10 on each so You'
make 20 grand
total yeah and use that you could buy a
used car for 10 grand to puts around in
for
now uh yeah I and then you know like our
family uh my wife my wife's family I
guess you know they got used so you look
at that and my wife's they're always
working on those cars so what is how
much is the benefit um well a reliable
used get rid of yes yeah they're so
expensive nowadays that's you know
that's the I think that's yeah you
purchased a really expensive car so you
definitely know but man you make 34
Grand buy a 10 $12,000 Honda Civic
that's going to get you guys around for
a year I'm not selling to live to to
drive it for 10 years but be driving it
for for a year Dustin I'm like because
what you guys need there's there's a
radical mindset shift that that needs to
happen for you guys you've been doing
your plan and it's not working you make
$350,000 and I'm not trying to come down
on you too hard Dustin but there's
people listening right now that think
holy crap's being nice they're angry at
Dustin going I could I could be doing so
much with that income and they're still
feeling stress like this is crazy so
there needs to be a there needs to be a
radical shakeup Dustin you guys re you
and your wife need to sit down and feel
like we we have do we've done this all
wrong like we have to do the complete
opposite of what we've been doing which
means selling stuff yes buying a $12,000
car I mean doing things that are so
different than what you guys have been
doing tackling this debt getting savings
because if I told you Dustin that gosh I
mean we could sit here and run the
numbers but I'm like I mean within
within nine months if you guys sold
these cars and took your income and
paused investing through everything at
it you could look up by next summer be
almost debt free and then you guys could
even look up and say oh my gosh you know
we could we're going to have savings
with that income having no payments no
payments how much you're going to be
able to save a 3 to six months worth of
expenses for an emergency fund have that
in place and then start investing like
your whole financial World dusting could
look completely different in 18 months
completely different but that means you
guys are going to have to do some really
different stuff and and I would
encourage you I want you to stay on the
line dtin because I want to give you
Financial Peace University this is our
nine lesson course that I want you and
your wife to sit down and go through
this is the basics of money and it is
the fastest way to build wealth from
point A to point B that's
sustainable and man I just I I'm so
hopeful and you guys live in Charleston
West Virginia you're not out in LA
California with insane yeah maky yeah
like you you guys can do this like you
have so much going for you you have so
much going for you but you have to have
the discipline you have to look at money
in a completely different way and it's
going to be uncomfortable but I think
that's good Dustin cuz you guys have
been real real comfortable for a while
until it's caught up with you so MH
continue that but man three $350,000 a
year can do a lot for you guys and it's
only working for the bank right now
you'll get there fast man if you follow
this plan this is the Ramsey Show